les pharmaciennes c'est à dire les
femmes qui ont un diplôme de pharmacie
préfère qu'on les appelle madame le
pharmacien car elles ne veulent pas
qu'on les confonde avec la femme du
pharmacien c'est ce qui ressort d'un
sondage publié aujourd'hui par un
quotidien professionnel voilà qui sans
doute ne fera pas plaisir à yvette roudy
qui a fait depuis longtemps son cheval
de bataille de la féminisation des noms
de profession madame la ministre il fait
du reste allusion dans le livre qu'elle
vient de publier chez albin michel à
cause d'elle un livre où elle fait le
bilan de son action au gouvernement mais
où elle raconte aussi les années
difficiles de son enfance christian
dauriac la rencontre et
j'ai vu un petit peu le désir de faire
le point et j'ai commencé à la faire
lorsque j'étais au parlement européen où
j'ai écrit presque 200 pages sur
masi finalement un petit peu parce que
des amis proches m'ont poussé et puis
par la suite j'ai été amené aussi à
faire le bilan parce qu'au bout de trois
ans et demi on a le sentiment qu'on peut
déjà faire un petit bilan d' d'exercice
est ce ministère ce livre vous enviez
envie de le lire avec le titre ma main
entre vous vous savez quand on a fini
d'écrire un livre il est ainsi que
derrière soi donc je le connais
évidemment tout à fait parker puisque
j'ai beaucoup travaillé il a fallu il a
fait organiser il a fallu réécrire
beaucoup de choses plusieurs fois et il
a fallu faire un tri il y a eu des
épreuves donc au moment où je vous parle
je n'ai pas envie de lire tout
simplement parce que parce que je le
connais trop bien alors je pense plutôt
en ce moment à ce que je suis en train
de faire ici au ministère ou peut-être
un autre livre que j'aurais envie de
faire et en vérité mais venu nos prix
des je me suis dit que j'aimerais écrire
maintenant la vie de ma mère à partir de
ce livre c'est une idée qui m'est venue
en chemin elle n'était pas venue avant
donc pourquoi mais parce que quand vous
êtes en train d'écrire un livre c'est un
travail sur vous même que vous faites et
ça vous fait découvrir beaucoup de
choses ça nous permet de faire le point
sur vous même vous ne pouvez pas être
approximatif pas ce que vous écrivez
donc il faut être beaucoup plus précis
que lorsque vous parlez il faut il faut
réfléchir davantage il faut faire des
tris et cela vous entraîne à une
réflexion sur vous même en profondeur
donc des idées nouvelles qui surgissent
c'est un travail sur soi en quelque
sorte